let's bring in the second lady of the
united states ms karen pence and the
leading ambassador for new for a new
mental health initiative good morning to
you
good morning ainsley thanks for having
me on you're welcome you're welcome
right before we get to that i do have to
ask you about your husband not wearing
the mask when he was touring the mayo
clinic
why wasn't he wearing one that's a great
question i'm glad that you asked me
first of all it was a great visit to
mayo they're doing amazing research
with the blood from recovering coven 19
patients
and as our medical experts have told us
uh wearing a mask prevents you from
spreading the disease and knowing that
he doesn't have covid19 uh he didn't
wear one it was actually after he
left mayo clinic that he found out that
they had a policy of asking
everyone to wear a mask so you know
someone who's worked on this
uh this whole uh task force for over two
months
is not someone who would have done
anything to offend anyone or
or hurt anyone or scare anyone so i'm
glad you gave me the opportunity to talk
about that
well thank you for coming on and talking
about it so suicide is up
domestic violence is up we just got the
jobless numbers 30 million people
without jobs
in our country because of covet mental
health is is on the forefront of all of
our minds and i know you're on a mission
to tackle that what are you doing
well the this president started a task
force
uh a three-year task force called
prevents and it's the president's
roadmap to empower veterans
to end the national tragedy of suicide
and provence has started a mental health
campaign
called more than ever before because
right now you know there
there's this mental health issue that
all of us are dealing with
everybody ainsley is struggling with
mental health right now
and so we see this as an opportunity to
get uh
the stigma taken away from mental health
because we all understand what this
feels like right now
and so more than ever before has four
main points
first of all check in with yourself
every day how are you doing
secondly what are the things that help
you what are the things that you do that
kind of
get you out of a low mood whether it's
reading or
cooking or gardening and then schedule
those things
into your day give a little bit of
structure to this
you know open-ended day that we're all
dealing with
third we want people to talk about their
struggles and their successes
especially if you have children at home
and they're worried about
when am i going to play soccer again
when do i get to see my teacher
i don't like the fact that my senior
prom was canceled
let them get those feelings out talk
about those struggles because it's okay
to not be okay but then talk about the
successes
what are some things your family's
learned about yourself over this time
what are some things you've accomplished
and lastly if people are struggling if
you're worried about yourself
or someone you love we encourage people
to call the suicide prevention lifeline
at 800-273-8255
and if you're military we also want you
to go to military one source
uh that's a place where we provide free
counseling
for military members and their family
members
and we also want people to go to
facebook.com
we are prevents and click on learn
more and we'll give you lots of
resources what we want people to know is
we're all in this together
we're all feeling these same stresses
right now and we want you to know there
is help
out there it's okay to not be okay
yes what a beautiful message and i feel
privileged to be able to talk to you and
spread that message to our country
because so many are hurting
and if we can prevent one life one
person from taking their life hopefully
we've been able to do that today
call that number you're valued you are
god's child and god has big plans for
your life thank you so much karen pence
we appreciate you being here
you're welcome and go to our website
foxandfriends.com
for uh directions on those numbers all
those links and that kind of thing